und nun eine weitere folge unserer
beliebten rubrik die 1000 größten
behörden deutschlands heute das booms
fidel umfeld bleibe ganz genau
sie wissen es in der box wie dem bremer
außenstelle des bundesamts für migration
und flüchtlinge bamf wurden zwischen
2013 und 2016 asylbescheide ohne
rechtsgrundlage erteilt ja
wahrscheinlich gegen geld sehr
wahrscheinlich wieviel asylbescheide
wann das genau unter 1000 fast fast 1200
waren es wohl möglicherweise danach
sieht alles aus haben anwälte zusammen
mit komplizen aus dem bremer bank
positive bescheide verkauft für bis zu
1000 euro pro person
diese filiale da vorerst keine fälle
mehr bearbeiten ich habe keine ahnung
was sie stattdessen machen die steine
spiel schiffe versenken hat horst
seehofer den laden noch im griff das ist
die frage
sein staatssekretär sagt neulich noch es
gibt überhaupt keine anzeichen dafür
dass in der zentrale des bundesamtes für
migration und flüchtlinge in nürnberg
irgend etwas vertuscht oder unter den
teppich gekehrt wurde die mails aus der
zentrale des bamf in nürnberg lassen
einen anderen schluss zu
der zuständige abteilungsleiter ordnete
zwei eine prüfung an schrieb aber weiter
wirken sie bitte geräuschlos wie
vorgeschlagen vorgehen ich möchte nicht
dass alles bis ins detail geprüft wird
ja ja natürlich ja nicht so genau
hingucken ist immer gut
hier ist es wie beim putzen hinter dem
kühlschrank wer weiß was man da findet
wenn es ganz blöd läuft scheitern
seehofers karriere an einer frau namens
josefa schmid sie hier
bis neulich noch leiterin des bremer
bank sie hat wohl die probleme entdeckt
und alarm geschlagen nach ihrer
darstellung wurde sie dafür
strafversetzt einen muss man sagen
vielseitig begabte frau die mal beinahe
schlagerkarriere gemacht hätte
[Musik]
nicht
gut man musste sich strafversetzt
hätte ich auch strafen ein ja da gibt es
jetzt unterschiedliche darstellung sie
hat wohl im märz eine art brand sms an
seehofer persönlich geschickt auf die
der herr minister aber nicht geantwortet
hat weil er wahrscheinlich das video von
eben kann und sich gedacht hat coco
konnte bereuen
seehofer muss jetzt aufräumen in seinem
besten mit einem dampfreiniger wenn sie
mich fragen die zustände in bremen waren
ja wirklich unfassbar
überlegen sie mal da sind asylbewerber
aus anderen bundesländern regelmäßig hin
gekappt worden
zum bescheide kaufen in bussen ich habe
heute bei der staatsanwaltschaft gefragt
ob ich mir das so vorstellen muss wie
bei einer butterfahrt muss voll hier
vorfahren und die antwort war ja so
ungefähr muss es wohl gewesen sein
butterfahrt zumba ist ein astreines
geschäftsmodell hits leider nicht mehr
dabei haben die anbieter so schöne
werbefilme produziert na ja lust auf
einem tagesausflug nach bremen das kein
cooler des nordens da sind sie bei uns
genau richtig beim ampera soll bescheid
und spaß dabei
[Musik]
obwohl flüchtlinge wer hat alles prima
das dach nicht mehr
[Musik]
er kann
so freunde jetzt spitzt mal die laus
schlappen ihr alle wollt asyl
das ist den richtigen bundesländern
hans-gerd schwierig ja darum fahren wir
nach dem ableben wird nämlich seit 73
jahren ununterbrochen von der spd
regiert ja deshalb ist die stadt auch
komplett im arsch der afghane zwei
syrien iraker ohne aus hildesheim die
glaubt wir fahren zum geburtshaus von
heino und hannelore so leute mal butter
bei die fische
ihr habt hier von euch back mir erstmal
hier 1000 euro rein
ja komm lass jucken kumpel 1000 mbit s
ist der loser pool was guckst du denn so
traurig deutschland kosten trägt ja ich
sag mal das phantasialand dieser audi
umsonst meine damen und herren wir sind
hier auf der rechten seite das berühmte
prima visa stadion wo noch so pelster
gehrmann superteam center world westhoff
bremen station kam
ich hoffe mal eben aus und hole
europäisch weide oder wie man in eurer
sprache sachen klima
was soll ich viele durchbruch heute ehrt
bescheide ich nehme hier oben die weg
vom stapel sind die alle unterschrieben
ach so und dann brauche ich noch ein
paar führerscheine und pässe hast du was
da an geht video bis morgen bisher beste
hier sind eure bestreitet ist noch warm
für die 1000 euro gibt's nicht nur
erfüllt nein es gibt ja auch noch eine
heizdecke dazu und die brandneue cd von
josefa schmid mit all ihren höhen
zu werden
weiter bonn
stelle
denn legal kann jeder
bei den damen und herren